first I wanted to start with you and
do's and don'ts of playing a convincing
hacker because it's not an easy thing to
pull off
I know I know so some of the do's and
playing a convincing hacker is don't try
to do too much I'm sure
hackers are you know and speaking
actually speaking with some some coders
I wouldn't say hackers I would say
coders okay that sounds more appropriate
yeah they're not like this it's like
sometimes it's it's pretty like basic
stuff I'll upload some software I sit
there I wait I do this I do that but for
the for the purposes of this character
some of the some of the do's were to
keep it keep it high energy for the sake
of it being a film keep it comedic you
know you you always want to keep the
audience entertained because yeah coding
can be boring at times you know what I
mean it can be so those are some might
do's and don'ts I would say is it fair
to say that if we get a bloodshot sequel
I want it to be you with the wonderful
actor who plays Eric and you just go toe
to toe funny I thought you were all
wonderful but I think he just took me by
surprise because I wasn't as familiar
with his work yeah oh my god he's so so
we all at one point and that dude is
funny
he rages we go running around Montreal
in Old Montreal like he's one of the
funniest people again no idea no that
was a Louis some stuff that didn't make
the movie but there was a kind of
animosity between my character and his
and he he actually has to still pick at
you you might even see it in the movie
and yeah so Mike my character I quite
enjoyed like tormenting him by stealing
his Pikachu and launching it across
I hear you're running the New York City
Marathon I am I've run you know quite a
few marathons and I I just something I
want to do for this year because it's a
big birthday year for me
but yeah I'm really excited to say it's
a big one it's their 50th anniversary so
55 I'm actually running for my own it's
called Mike peek challenge I have we've
raised over 5 million dollars for
charity and we support several charities
from like leukemia lymphoma research to
this year the Environmental Defense Fund
so it's it's really rewarding yeah it's
something that should be celebrated so
I'm joined me about I'm gonna do know I
did it last year I've done we did it
how was it it was incredible yeah
probably one of the best things in my
entire life yeah you had great weather
as well we did have great yeah I I pray
for the same for you what times you get
yeah I was 414 nice yeah I couldn't
believe ingress pleasantly surprised big
congrats to you with opportunities yeah
I was I was one hour in six minutes I
crushed it so I gotta leave it or what
no no I run walk actually I walk faster
than most people can run so I don't let
you know I'm a star that's dud you guys
go I got a quickie around them would you
rather for you they're just fun silly
questions would you rather have to fake
sneeze or fake vomit at a scene I've I
have fake vomit in it you have put it I
knew you sometimes use they give you
like something to put in your mouth like
maybe soup or something but after doing
a few times you actually it does somehow
make you wanna vomit that's why it
freaks me out I would rather do that
because fake sneezing I feel like I look
like it dummy like really but I can
easily go into bad actor mode so I faked
vomiting like you could you right you
can get there outside rather do that and
you do both the same time then yeah okay
hmm-hmm-hmm-hmm that's really good thank
you very much that's unique I'll give
you that told you I was the stars would
you rather have to eat a lot in the
scene or run a lot in the scene I'd
rather run a lot cuz there is some
benefit to it you know what I mean and
they know when you're tired yeah and
what do you eat in a scene then you have
to redo it and do it over and over and
over and but I'm you're just really sick
of doughnuts yeah
yeah and your cholesterol high no would
you rather work with a super experienced
director who makes you nervous or a
first-time feature filmmaker that you
don't know if they could pull it off I
take wholesome I don't know yeah but
he's the thing he's already even though
he's a first-time feature director he he
doesn't feel that way because he came in
with a vision already a lot of
first-time directors don't have a vision
and they're did they're relying on you
to give them the vision he was like nope
here's my vision great